we're about to travel through a mouse's
leg bone
this tiny canal normally carries blood
into or out of the bone marrow
researchers have known for a long time
that bones have an efficient system of
blood vessels to enable immune cells
made here in the bone marrow to move
quickly into general circulation but
they've only just managed to see the
many microscopic vessels that play a key
role in that process as we zoom out you
can see lots of small holes marking the
entrance and exit points of these teeny
capillaries without knowing it trauma
surgeons have been making use of this
fast and direct transport system for
years when they can't get quick access
to a patient's veins instead they inject
drugs or fluid directly into the
patient's leg bone this technique first
developed by the military and used on
battlefields is called intraosseous
infusion to figure out how intraosseous
infusions work scientists turned to a
technique called clearing this involves
washing away the fatty membranes that
surround cells to make whole organs
see-through it's been applied to many
structures including hearts making bones
see-through has proved to trickier but
recently a team in Germany managed it
this mouse bone the size of a matchstick
is a tibia or leg bone the team found
that by using a chemical called ethyl
cinemate a component of cinnamon they
could make the opaque bone become like
glass leaving the blood vessels intact
and visible now using a microscope the
researchers could examine the blood
vessels they could clearly see the large
arteries and veins that are known to
carry blood in and out of the bone
marrow but looking more closely they
also noticed hundreds of tiny blood
vessels running straight through the
bone from the bone marrow to the outside
the team named them transcortical
vessels or TC V's what's more by
staining a kind of immune cell called a
neutrophil the team was able to watch
immune cells the yellow blobs actually
traveling through the T series these
long overlooked vessels seem to play a
really important role in bony physiology
in fact the team calculated that the
majority of blood flowing in and out of
bones actually passes through them and
these vessels are not unique to long leg
bones
a few months ago another team described
similar microscopic channels that cross
the skull and connect directly with the
surface of the brain this rather blurry
video also shows immune cells moving
through the channels understanding how
immune cells move from the bone marrow
to local sites of injury or disease
could help us to treat stroke as well as
inflammatory bone conditions such as
arthritis so far the experiments have
been done in mouse models of these
conditions but the team's suspect that T
Seavey's are common in human bones too
to look for them one of the authors did
an MRI scan of his own leg this is a
cross-section of his thigh if we focus
on the bone and then zoom in you can see
tiny holes that look like the openings
to the tiny vessels seen in mice signs
of a network of previously unrecognized
blood channels that open up new routes
for medical research
you